Ja gerne.
Okay, er würde ich ihr Reparationen,
ich werde da zu einer Filmung kommen,
die ich gleich so üben habe.
Okay.
Wie heißt ihr?
Mein Name ist Hans Müller.
Hans Müller.
Okay.
Tabu et.
Tabu.
Okay.
Was man gesagt hat?
Mit?
Double-L.
Ja, Double-L.
Okay.
Wie heißt ihr?
Ich bin 30 Jahre alt.
30.
Wann ist ihr noch geboren?
Ich bin am 15.04.1992 geboren.
Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,80 m groß.
Okay.
Wie viel wegen Sie denn?
79 kg.
Okay.
Herr Müller, wie kann ich Ihnen heute was für Beschwerde haben Sie?
Und zwar folgendes, ich hatte vor drei Wochen Fußball gespielt.
Ja.
Und beim Fußballspiel hatte ich dann einen plötschen Schmerz in meinem Knie gehabt,
in meinem rechten Knie.
Rechten Knie.
Es war so, dass ich mit dem Gegner zusammen gestoßen bin
und ich habe meinen Knie verdreht.
Ich habe es in den Schmerz gefahren.
Ich bin nicht hingefahren.
Nach diesem Vertreter-Trauma, seitdem habe ich Schmerzen
in meinem rechten Kniegelenk.
Okay.
Können Sie auf dieser Beine gut auftreten?
Ja, ich kann laufen.
Es geht.
Aber am Anfang nicht eine Woche lang hatte ich stärkere Schmerzen.
Ich habe dann ein bisschen Ibuprofen genommen.
Ich habe gekühlt.
Und jetzt kann ich relativ gut laufen.
Aber ich habe Probleme, wenn ich in den Knie gehe
oder wenn ich beim Auto aussteige, wenn ich mir in den Beinen verdrehe,
habe ich dann Schmerzen.
Mein Knie ist ein bisschen dick geworden.
Dick geworden.
Okay.
Ich habe Schmerzen in meinem Rechten gefahren.
Nein, das ist auf der Innenseite meines Kniegelenkes.
Ich trage es nicht aus.
Können Sie bitte diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind sie eher stechend oder ziehend oder dumm?
Ich würde sagen, ein stechender Schmerz.
Also es ist nicht dauernd, dauernd auf der Schmerz,
bei bestimmten Bewegungen ist es ein stechender Schmerz.
Aber in Ruhe haben Sie keine Schmerzen?
In Ruhe habe ich keine Schmerzen.
Das war die erste Woche.
Auch in Ruhe hatte ich Schmerzen.
Nachts hatte ich Schmerzen.
Aber mittlerweile geht es mir gut.
Aber ich habe immer noch Schmerzen in meinem Knie,
wenn ich bei bestimmten Belastungen.
Wenn ich mit dem Knie voll den Schmerz schmierst,
dann geht es gut.
Bei den Schmerzen geht es wirklich gut.
Bei den Schmerzen habe ich Schmerzen.
Ich kann nicht runter in die Knie gehen.
Also die maximale Beugung ist eingeschränkt.
Okay.
gibt es etwas, was diese Schmerzen verstarke, Sie haben schon gesagt, weil wir
zum Beispiel, wenn man beim Auto aussteigen, weil man den Knie
bisschen verdreht, da tut es weh, beim Treppen laufen tut es weh, wenn ich Treppen
runterlaufen möchte zum Beispiel, also bei bestimmten Situationen tut es weh, wenn
ich ganz beugen möchte tut es weh, bei normalen Laufen geht es eigentlich, es tut zwar weh, aber es geht.
Sie haben dagegen Ibuprofen eingenommen, das hat ein wenig geholfen.
Genau, für den Anfang hat es gut geholfen und jetzt habe ich auch Schmerzen.
Okay, gibt es etwas, was die Schmerzen verbessert oder?
Nee, also nur wenn ich die Ibuprofen nehme oder wenn ich grün ist, auch ein bisschen lederum da.
Auf einer Schmerzskala, wobei ein sehr leicht, aber sehr feststatt ist, wie bewerten Sie es?
Also aktuell, wenn die Belastung situationisch da ist, würde ich sagen, habe ich 2.
Okay.
Aber wenn ich beim Auto aussteige, dieser kurze Moment, dann ist es bestimmt 7.
7.
Haben Sie in diesem Gelände etwas auffälliges bemerkt, wie Überwärmung oder Rötung?
Nee, keine Rötung oder keine Überwärmung.
Aber es gibt...
Leichter Schwellung, wenig, also ist es nicht so ganz dick, aber man merkt zwischen meinem linken
und rechtsen Knien, dass meine rechte Kniebis sind dicker.
Wenn Sie in diesem Bereich türke, dann fühlen Sie sich etwas anderes, Flüssigkeit zum Beispiel?
Nee, weiß ich nicht, also ich kann da drücken, ist total...
Oder eine Geräusche, Knarschen oder Geräusche oder so?
Nee, Geräusche, dann echt.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie auch Taupas, Krippen, Krippen an dieser Seite?
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Oder Kraftverletzung?
Kraftverletzung habe ich auch nicht.
Okay.
Bei dieser Erartung hatten Sie andere Verletzungen?
Nee, ich hatte nur Kleinfeld.
Hatten Sie schon einmal andere Unfall?
Anderen Unfall, wo im Knie meint sie?
Knie oder andere Körperteile?
Meint sie früher?
Früher, ja, ich meinte früher.
Natürlich als Kind bin ich sehr oft gefahren.
Diese Sportler, ja.
Ja, aber als Kind fährt man immer viel hin, mal Knie, mal Ellenbogen, Fahrrad gestürzt.
Moment.
Ich meinte eine relevante Verletzung zum Beispiel, eine Bruch oder so.
Bruch, bis jetzt wurde ich nicht operiert oder irgendwas wegen einem Unfall.
Okay, das war es.
Und jetzt würde gerne ich über Ihre allgemeine Gesundheit durchdurch dann etwas fragen.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Fieber habe ich nicht, nein.
Fühlen Sie sich fieblich?
Nein.
Okay, oder Schweiß aus Brüche?
Darf ich aus?
Nein.
Und wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Appetit ist gut, normal.
Normal?
Hab Sie in letzter Zeit Gerüsche zugenommen oder?
Nein, ich bin immer ungefähr gleich gerichtet.
Ich bin nur 1 Kilometer alt.
Okay.
Haben Sie Herzrausen, Herzpulpitationen oder Herztorbenen bemerkt?
Nein.
Ne.
Hüsten oder Atmungnot?
Oder Torach?
Busschmerzen, Busskorbschmerzen?
Nein.
Okay.
Sie können andere Körperparte gut bewegen.
Ja.
Okay.
Und wie ist Ihre Schlaf?
Mein Schlaf, der ist gut.
Gut.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Nein.
Darf ich wissen, wie soll Sie das alles fragen?
Ja, ich muss über eine Information in Ihrer Körper wissen.
Um Sie gut zu helfen können.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Allergie?
Allergie?
Ja, Gräser und Polnallergie.
Gräser, Gras.
Gras.
Okay.
Und wie oisert sich Polen?
Ja, Polnallergie.
Okay.
Im Frühjahr kriege ich dann immer, da läuft meine Nase und meine Augen, die jucken.
Nehmen Sie dagegen etwas oder?
Ja, wie heißt das?
Zitrin oder so was heißt es ähnlich, heißt das nehme ich mal einen manchmal.
Manchmal.
Und gegen Grasallergie?
Ja, das ist ja auch so.
Wie oisert sich diese Allergie?
Ja, auch irgendwie, dass meine Nase läuft, Augen läuft, wahrscheinlich, weil ich den Kontakt habe, oder so mit den Gräser.
Okay.
Leiden Sie an Irgendwas für Erkrankungen, Hamla?
Ich meinte chronische Erkrankungen wie Schuturysenprobleme, oder Bluthochdruck, oder so.
Ja, genau.
Nehmen Sie außer Medikamente, Ibuprofen, gegen aktuelle Mäschwerde?
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente?
Nein.
Keine Medikamente.
Wie sehr wurden Sie operiert?
Wie haben Sie schon fernankt?
Also durch Unfallverletzung nicht, aber ich hatte mal, wo ich 15 Jahre alt war, hatte ich eine Blindamoperation gehabt.
Okay, mit 15.
Ja.
Okay.
Und ja, Rachelsee?
Nein.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Bei Gelegenheit, also bei Feier und so weiter.
Was trinken Sie denn?
Meistens Bier.
Ja.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Alpharok mit dem Drogen?
Drogen?
Ich weiß nicht, wie es getrieben wird.
Ja, ganz.
Ja.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Kinderheit, Krankheit, auch gegen Tetenoze oder Corona.
Also ich weiß nicht, wie die alle heißen, aber mein Hausarzt, der übt mich regelmäßig.
Ich habe alle Impfungen, was nötig ist.
Mhm.
Ich wüsste aber nicht, wie die alle heißen.
Okay.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Asthant?
Nein.
Okay.
Ich glaube, ihr seid noch lebt.
Ja.
Und wie ist die Vater?
Ja, mein Vater ist gesund, aber nimmt Medikamente ein.
Mhm.
Was nimmt ihr?
Irgendwie, wie die heißen, die Medikamente weiß ich nicht.
Er hat gesagt, dass er mal wegen Bluthochdruck Medikamente nimmt.
Okay.
Und die Mutter nimmt wegen der Schildrüse Medikamente ein.
Wie das heißt, weiß ich nicht.
Schildrüse unter Funktion oder unter Funktion, wissen Sie?
Weiß ich nicht, nein, kann ich nicht sagen.
Ich weiß nur, dass sie Schildrüse Medikamente einnimmt.
Okay.
Haben Sie Geschwester?
Ich habe einen Bruder, ja.
Ist der gesund?
Ja.
Der ist jünger als ich und der ist gesund.
Gott sei Dank, ja.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Bankkaufmann.
Bankkaufmann.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein.
Hab ich Kinder?
Hab ich auch nicht, nein.
Sie sind Sportler?
Hab ich richtig?
Ja, also ich spiele regelmäßig Fußball in einem Fußballverein.
Ja, wie viel?
Aber nicht amateurhaft oder professionell, sondern einfach regelmäßig.
Bewegen Sie sich?
Genau, seit ich klein bin, spiele ich immer Fußball.
Das ist sehr gut.
Haben Sie Stress beim Arbeit oder im Privatleben?
Nein, nicht so besonders.
Nehmen Sie alleine?
Nein, mit meiner Freundin.
Freundin, okay.
Gut Herr Müller, ich habe meinerzeit alle wichtige Fragen Ihnen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas in Zufügen oder etwas fragen?
Was fragen?
Wie geht es weiter?
Jetzt haben Sie sehr viel gefragt, aber ich bin nicht mitgekommen.
Was machen Sie jetzt?
Ich werde jetzt sicherlich untersuchen.
Und dann vielleicht werde ich auch einige weitere Untersuchungen
für die
Keine Frage.
Okay. Darf ich wegenan?
Ja.
Okay.
Guten Abend.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patient aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen vorstellen.
Hätten Sie dafür sein?
Ja, deswegen bin ich hier. Bitte schön.
Danke.
Es handelt sich um Hans Müller.
und 9 und 7,7 kg.
Er kam heute wegen Zeitgleichbogen,
bestehend der Schmerz im Rechtenknie,
gelangt, bei der Bewegelung und Bezahndarst
Bewegelung zu uns kam.
Und da ging,
er hat gekühlt,
diese HB ihnen wenig geholfen,
aber die Schmerzen hätten sich im Verlauf verschlechtert.
Auf einer Schmerzschmallach legen die Schmerzen in Ruhe bei...
Im Verlauf verbessert.
Anfangs war sehr schlimm, und jetzt ist weniger.
Nur bei Belastung ist schlecht.
Vorher war es die ganze Zeit schlimm.
Okay, okay.
Jetzt in Ruhe bei 7,
bei 7 von wie viel? 100 oder bei 7 von 20?
Ja, okay.
Besonders, er hat Schwierigkeit beim Beugen des Rechtenknie.
Und bei 5,5 Bewegelung,
ich meinte zum Beispiel Treppen, Steigen oder Direktion, Auto aussteigen.
Von Auto hat er Schwierigkeit dabei.
Und die Schmerzen würden nicht ausstrahlen.
Darf man sich auch auf diese Seite eine Schwellung gehalten?
Die Frage nach weiteren Bechwerden,
wurde fernheit.
Die Erreichnis, Pasierte,
Bayern-Futbauspieler,
er hat er ist mit Zaynem Gehtnerin,
Susamun Gehtoslin,
hat er eine Stärkenschmerzen verspürt.
Er hat für Erkrankungen eine Erkannung,
mit 5 Stich,
ist eine Abandöktomie bei Bayern-Futbauspieler.
Er hat Allergie gegen Gläser und Polen.
Polen-Ellergie oysert zicht-Eisgenitis
und Konjuktivitis auch Gras-Ellergie.
Der Impfstatus ist vollständig.
Zayn Fata leidet an arterialen Hypertonien,
Zayn Mutha leidet an einem Schilderüssungsproblem.
Aber er wusste nicht, ob es eine Hypoteroide oder Hyperteroide ist.
Er ist Bankkaufmann,
ist Leidig und lebt mit seinen Nervenfreunden.
Er ist Sportler,
ist Tribalregal-Mystikspot in einem Verein.
Er hat keine Kinder.
Aufgrund der Anamnestischenangaben
gehe ich von einer Menyskopete
aus, in der rechten Knie.
Als differenzial Diagnose
käme eine Bandverletzung
aus Kreuzbandträger
und Patella-Luxation in Betracht.
Ich habe die Medizinerin
mit einer Motorengerung und Sensität
verwendet.
Ich habe auch eine Reflexkontrolle.
Ich habe auch eine Makbunäne
für die Menyskopete.
Ich habe auch eine Menyskopete.
Ich habe eine Schubladen-Test
für die Kreuzband-Krist.
Ich würde die Untersuchung durchführen.
Was würden Sie als Ergänzens
zu Ihrer klinischen Untersuchung durchführen lassen?
Was würden Sie durchführen lassen?
Was würde Sie durchführen lassen?
Ich brauche noch 2 Untersuchungen.
Eine Röntgen des linken Kniegelenks
und auch eine MRT.
Die rechtsen Kniegelenken.
Wenn Sie zum Radiologen schicken, was schreiben Sie auf die Anforderung? Was wollen Sie für einen Röntgen haben?
Ich suche eine Fraktur eigentlich. Wenn eine Fraktur gibt, ja.
Wie heißt die Anforderung? Das heißt, was wollen Sie genau haben? Was soll der Radiolog Röntgen?
Was soll der Radiolog Röntgen haben?
Welches Olga haben Sie?
Der Röntgen ist die Kniegelenk im Zybald Ebenen.
Ja, genau. Die Kniegelenk in zwei Ebenen.
Und unten kann man zusätzlich schreiben Ausschlussfraktur. Frakturfragizeichen zum Beispiel.
Frakturzeichen, ja.
Und Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie noch eine zweite Untersuchung machen würden. Was wäre das?
Das könnte eine MRT sein. Durch die MRT kann ich Kreuzband-Fist oder Meniskopete ausschließen.
Okay.
Waschteil-Parlation Besonders kann ich ausschließen.
Ja.
Da hat es hier zwischen Röntgenaufnahme und MRT-Aufnahme grob gesagt.
Haben Sie schon ein bisschen gesagt, können Sie es nochmal machen?
Okay. Durch die Radiologischen Tarzüge kann ich Knokonschütterung zu Zypen Besonders.
Aber über die Waschteil gibt Radiologischen Tarzüge fast nichts.
Aber bei der MRT können wir viel Informationen bekommen.
Über die Waschteil-Gewerbe.
Und auch Kreuzband.
Und auch Ben tendon.
Und die Kolateral-Benda.
Ja. Kolateral-Benda.
Können wir oder auch Erguss, wenn es eine gibt?
Okay.
Wie gehen Sie voran?
Was empfehlen Sie dem Patienten?
Es ist so, dass wir MRT nicht gleich machen können.
Weil es sehr viele Termine dafür gibt.
Also sehr viele Wartezeit dafür gibt.
Sehr viele Patienten brauchen dieses MRT in dem Krankenhaus.
Nachdem Sie geröntcht haben, Sie haben eine Faktor aufgeschlossen.
Und er hat Schmerzen. Was empfehlen Sie ihm?
Was soll er machen?
Ja, wir müssen einen Rist auszulassen.
Oder einen Meskopete auszulassen.
Vielleicht, der Patient hat eine Walter-Operation.
Deswegen werde ich stationäre Aufnehmen.
Ich habe alles in einem bisschen Schnatz zu machen.
Oder ich habe mich beigeläumt.
Ja, in der Regel ist es so, dass man wegen Miniskopatin die Situation aufnimmt.
Die Eingriffe sind in der Regel Ambulanz hier in Deutschland.
Es ist ein Ambulanteingriff.
Es gibt andere Risikofaktoren, wie zum Beispiel eine Oma oder Opa.
Aber die haben dann andere Probleme.
Weniger als Miniskopatin.
Deswegen würde man den Patienten erst mal versorgen.
Mit einer, zum Beispiel, NSR, Voltarin-Salven-Verband.
Den Knie.
Kühlen empfehlen.
Schonen, eventuell mit unterm Gehstützen laufen.
Damit die Schade nicht größer wird.
Weniger Belastung.
Weniger Belastung, also leicht Belastung.
Also mit Bodenkontakt, aber leicht entlasten.
Und wir würden dann empfehlen, dass man ein MRT durchführt.
Und dann würde man aufklären, wenn es bei bestimmten Lesionen,
bei bestimmten Miniskus-Lesionen sollte man sich operativ vorstellen
und darüber sprechen.
Bei bestimmten Lesionen muss man nicht unbedingt operieren, sozusagen.
Das ist abhängig von, was dort ist.
Ob da ein Miniskus-Lesion ist, Knorpel-Lesion ist.
Und da eine Kreuzbandstruktur ist.
Jeder Kreuzbandstruktur-Mechanismus muss nicht operiert werden.
Wenn es nicht stabil ist, kann man das auch konservativ behandeln.
Es hat den Fußballspielen, dann empfehlt man doch trotzdem die Operation in der Regel.
Also dann würde man ein MRT untersuchen machen.
Und abhängig davon würde man eventuell operieren.
Eine ambulante Prüfung, dann nicht.
Okay.
Also NSHR, weiter einnehmen, kühlen und ein MRT soll der Patient organisieren,
und das er da bekommt.
Okay, ich mach das.
Also eine Schmerztherapie.
Und dann muss die Schlimmerwirt entlasten.
Und MRT durchführen.
Das wäre die Realität.
Okay, ambulante Prüfung.
Weil er hat ja gesagt, dass er laufen kann.
Zur Schmerztherapie kann man einen Tag, man vielleicht stationär aufnehmen,
wenn einer nicht laufen kann, weil er heute frisch gestürzt ist.
Er kann nicht laufen.
Er ist immobil, hat Schlaggeschmerzen.
Oder Erguss.
Erguss, und dann kann man auch sagen, wir nehmen sich stationär auf
und versuchen einen MRT zu machen, während seines Aufenthalts.
Okay.
Gut.
Hat jemand Fragen in der Gruppe oder Sie?
Haben Sie Fragen?
Vielleicht, ich kann über die Operation etwas fragen.
Wie führen Lapparoscopy-Operation durch?
Lapparoscopy ist der Atmoskopie.
Atmoskopie.
Hab ich früher auch den Fehler gemacht gehabt.
Kein Problem.
Man kann Atroskopie zweierlei Hinsicht machen.
Das eine ist Diagnostik, kann man auch eine Diagnostik-Atroskopie machen.
Wenn man im MRT nicht sicher ist, wenn man es nicht weiß, was er hat
und MRT sagt gar nichts und trotzdem hat er noch Schmerzen,
dann kann man sagen, MRT kann man nicht 100% egal sehen.
Wir machen eine Diagnostik-Atroskopie.
Oder man kann währenddessen auf eine therapeutische Lapparoscopie
auf der Stelbe Atroskopie.
Therapeutisch, dass man Meniskusglättung macht
oder Knorpelglättung macht, wenn da instabile Knorpelstücke sind.
Atroskopie, meistens machen wir eine Atroskopie.
Bei dem Alter hat man keine Atrose,
dass man eine Knieprothese denkt.
Bei älteren Leuten, die auch eine andere Frage sind,
wie würde die Diagnose heißen bei ihnen?
Es gibt eine Diagnose, die kann man auf jeden Fall sagen.
Meniskopäte?
Nein, das ist eine Verdachtsdiagnose.
Wir wissen das ja nicht.
Vielleicht ist es ja Knorpel.
Aber eine Diagnose ist sicher.
Er hat ja gesagt, dass er das Knie verdreht hat.
Das ist eine feste Diagnose.
Oder wenn kein Trauma wäre,
hätte man auch sagen können, eine Gonalgie.
Das ist auch eine feste Diagnose.
Das Knie-Gonalgie-Knie tut weh.
Das ist eine Diagnose.
Also, würde die Diagnose dann heißen,
das Knie-Glenk-Distation rechts,
mit Verdacht auf,
in einem Meniskus,
das ist eine Diagnose,
die die Diagnose ist.
Das ist eine Diagnose,
das knie-glenk-Distation rechts,
mit Verdacht auf, in einem Meniskus,
Lesion.
Mit Differenzialdiagnostik könnte man sagen,
er hat eine Knieglängs-Distitution,
mit Verdacht auf,
seit mal der Collateralband-Läsion,
oder Kreuzband-Läsion,
oder irgendwas.
Oder Knorpel-Läsion.
Aber die feste Diagnose,
Aber die feste Diagnose würde heißen, weil er, oder Liegamentruktur, Lesion, wenn man
nicht so genau weiß, bin ich der Freund, dass ich immer sage Lesion.
Lesion kann alles sein, Ruktur oder Heilruktur oder nur eine Dehnung.